[Applaus]
[Musik]
september 2020 haben wir ein video mit
dem titel was taugt putins armee
veröffentlicht und es wurde damals zu
einer unserer kontroversesten videos der
youtube algorithmus spülte und einen
haufen tut ihr fenster und deutsch
sprechende rosa nationalisten in den
kanal und diese dies leisten und hinten
ist als hätten wir gerade den drachen
lord zu germany's next topmodel gekürt
wobei dieser idee heute gar nicht mehr
so abwegig erscheint rund ein drittel
der zuschauer gerne den video damals ein
dislike insgesamt sechs mal mehr als der
normalerweise einfahren und so wie bei
keinem anderen unserer videos dabei
hatten wir nur anhand konkreter fakten
und daten kühl analysiert wie groß die
modernisierungs defizite nach putins
erster großer armeereform noch immer
sind und welche gewaltiger graben
zwischen sein und schein der russischen
streitkräfte kluft zwischen anspruch und
realität mit anderen worten wir fanden
putin hätte er eine parade armee für den
roten platz und propaganda shows im
staatsfernsehen als eine für die
ansprüche moderner kopf führung des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts gerüstet
das militär nun mehr als anderthalb
jahre später haben uns viele zuschauer
darum gebeten ein update zu diesem video
zu bringen denn zum einen hat der
russische krieg in der ukraine ja
gezeigt dass alle von uns angebracht und
70 punkte der wahrheit entsprachen zum
anderen jedoch auch dass die defizite
noch viel weitreichender sind als von
uns vorher gesagt seit dem beginn ihrer
invasion in der ukraine haben die
russischen streitkräfte herbe
rückschläge erlebten sie mussten die
belagerung kias aufgeben nachdem sie
mehrere wochen lang versucht hatten die
ukrainische hauptstadt einzunehmen es
war ihm unmöglich die lufthoheit über
der ukraine zu erlangen einem modernen
krieg unverzichtbares element und sie
steckten bei ihrer großoffensive im
donbass in einem stellungskrieg fest
gedenken daher dass gerade dies der
richtige zeitpunkt ist bilanz zu ziehen
und daraus auch vorhersagen zu den
weiteren kriegs verlaufen die zukunft
russlands als militärmacht treffen zu
können wir werden unser update wieder
als trilogie auflegen heute werden wir
uns auf den zustand der armee selbst der
militärstrategie und ein technische
fragen konzentrieren im zweiten teil
werden wir eine bewertung der russischen
waffensysteme vornehmen sowie den status
quo und die zukunft der russischen
rüstungsindustrie beleuchten und als
abschluss die ukraine selbst den
dortigen kriegsverlauf und seine
bedeutung zu das schicksal russlands als
mit hermacht analysieren wir werden
heute auch nicht über die gräueltaten
und kriegsverbrechen der wir sprechen
außer über ihren strategischen aspekt
diese sind so ungeheuerlich dass sie
vollkommen separat betrachtet werden
müssen also lasst uns loslegen
fangen wir mit einem nüchternen zahlen
vergleich an so sei auf dem papier die
russische armee gegen die der ukraine
vor dem krieg aus
mit anderen worten der vergleich fiel
eindeutig aus russland verfügt über ein
viel größeres lädt er als die ukraine
mehr noch wenn etwas putin russlands
charakterisiert dann ist es der extrem
militarismus chauvinistischer ausprägung
welcher die gesamte gesellschaft und
kultur des landes dominiert
wir haben hier auch visuell politik
bereits darüber gesprochen der kreml hat
sogar eine kathedrale gebaut die seine
streitkräfte gewidmet ist die meisten
beobachter sind daher davon ausgegangen
dass russische soldaten innerhalb
weniger tage kiew und die wichtigsten
technischen städte einnehmen würden doch
nach mehr als zwei monaten hat russland
noch keine einzige großstadt außer mario
pohl einnehmen können verlässlichen
quellen zufolge hat russland bereits
mehr als 23.000 soldaten 190 flugzeuge
155 hubschrauber und über 1000 panzer
verloren diese zahlen übersteigen die
verluste der us army in den gesamten 20
jahren des krieges in afghanistan
natürlich haben auch die ukraine hohe
verluste zu beklagen aber das war zu
erwarten
angeblich waren ist ja die russen die
alle trümpfe im ärmel hatten mit anderen
worten das russische militär hat in
seiner geschichte schon mehrfach versagt
aber trotzdem habe die meisten experten
erwartet dass putins reformen diesmal
funktionieren würden und ich frage mich
nur wie viele von diesen experten damals
unser video dislike haben aber gut von
welchen misserfolgen konkret reden wir
hier eigentlich
nun eigentlich von georgien bis
tschetschenien alle kriege welche die
russische föderation geführt hat waren
sehr bittere 7 russland hat die
tschetschenien kriege gewonnen aber um
den preis tausende eigener soldaten zu
verlieren zum teil durch eigenen
beschuss und ich weiß dass einige von
euch denken das ist pure anti russische
propaganda aber nein selbst wladimir
putin war sich bewusst dass seine armee
für einen modernen krieg nicht bereit
war deshalb hat der kreml im jahr 2008
alle ressourcen darauf verwendet seine
armee fit für das 21 jahrhundert zu
machen die arbeit die putin auf zwei
schlüsselfiguren sergej schoigu seinem
engen freund und verteidigungsminister
und valerie gasimov den chef des
generalstabs der russischen streitkräfte
ich möchte dass ihr euch diesen namen
gut einprägt valerie gelassen auf
er wird in diesem video und ab jetzt auf
dem weiteren tricks verlauf eine immer
bedeutendere rolle spielen hast du ein
langjähriger anhänger von sozialpolitik
bist wird dir dieser name eventuell
bekannt vorkommen er ist ein
militärischer rockstar der in der
gesamten militär komitee respektiert
wird sogar von seinem nato gegnern viele
sagen er sei der geistige vater des
konzepts der next generation award er
also der kriegsführung der nächsten
generation daher dachten eigentlich alle
dass die russischen streitkräfte mit
gras an der spitze das sowjetische erbe
aufgeben und ins 21 jahrhundert
eintreten würden aber nun sehen wir das
in russland ein altes sprichwort das zu
sowjetzeiten aufzuhören war noch immer
gilt die menschen tun so als würden sie
arbeiten und die regierung tut so als
würde sie sie bezahlen ein weiteres
sprichwort von damals wären nicht beim
staat cloud beklaut seine familie auch
dieses motto das in russland auch immer
bis in die obersten ränge der
generalität beherzigt wird hat
maßgeblichen anteil am zustand der
russischen streitkräfte und geheimdienst
wird als auch im gesamten verlauf dieses
krieges general staatschef valéry grass
erzählt jedoch nicht zu jenen generälen
die sich vom budget für die wartung
ihres kriegsgeräts lieber schöne villen
auf der krim gekauft haben als
soziologie und freund putins ist er auch
so etwas sicher nicht angewiesen er ist
auch nicht zu verwechseln mit seinem
ebenfalls aus der qatar metropole kazan
stammenden namensvetter dem generalmajor
witali gelassen auf vesta war bis vor
kurzem stabschef der einundzwanzigste
armee und ist bereits in der nähe von
hergefallen ukrainische scharfschützen
und knoten dürften sich hier noch auch
schon das foto von valerie neben ihr
fadenkreuz gepinnt haben denn putin hat
seinen generalstabschef höchstpersönlich
an die front ebenfalls bei celtic
beordert
[Musik]
so und was er jetzt in diesen kurzen
clip seht ist der nette begrüßung salut
den ihm die ukrainische artillerie
bereitet hat nur kurz nachdem er in
seinem kommandostand in der nähe von ihr
sie um angekommen war um dort mit 40
anderen hochrangigen offizieren eine
lagebesprechung abzuhalten 20 von ihnen
überlebten sie nicht unter anderem auch
ein general der elektronische
streitkräfte der rest darunter war der
regel russell aufkam verletzt mit dem
leben davon am ende dieses videos werdet
ihr genau verstehen was putin mit der
entsendung eines generalstabschefs an
die vorderste front gezeigt hat und
wieso russland darauf angewiesen ist
dass sich seine generäle in allerhöchste
gefahr begeben und dort in so großer
zahl um kommen in keinem anderen krieg
das ganze ist ein höchst
außergewöhnlicher vorgang ja dieser
krieg wirklich anders als alle anderen
zuvor und das in vielerlei hinsicht
aufgrund der überragenden fähigkeiten
ukrainische streit dass der russische
waffen zu zerstören und zu erbeuten oder
unglaublich in effizienten logistik
infrastruktur der russen kostete dieser
krieg etwa eine halbe milliarde dollar
pro tag und ist damit bei weiteren der
teuerste krieg aller zeiten die waffen
technischen gründe dafür werden wir uns
im nächsten video ansehen im heutigen
werden sind uns die frage stellen warum
herrscht im russischen militär ein
derartiges chaos und sowie inkompetenz
was genau ist eigentlich mit den
russischen streitkräften los wie ist es
möglich dass ein so autoritäres land mit
einer so militaristischen kultur ein
derart des organisiertes militär hat und
welche art von militär nutzt sogar seine
obersten generäle als kanonenfutter
heute werden wir all diese fragen
beantworten und keine angst dieses video
wird kein platter fremdschäm porno wir
werden alles sehr sachlich auf rollen
und tiefgründig hinterfragen und zwar
wie so oft in dem sie zuerst mit ein
wenig geschichte beschäftigen
das ausbildungs defizit
wir alle haben die bilder von russischen
soldaten gesehen die von der ukraine
gefangen genommen worden die ukrainische
propaganda hat ist sich zur aufgabe
gemacht diese bilder mit großem tamtam
zu verbreiten damit wir alle sehen wie
sie ihre mamas anrufen und vor ihnen
rumpf wenn man mag von dieser art show
halten was man will aber es gibt etwas
sehr interessantes an diesen bildern was
alle soldaten sind sehr jung auf den
meisten videos sind die soldaten nicht
einmal 20 jahre alt und das deutet auf
eines hält es sind soldaten mit sehr
wenig ausbildung dies erklärt zum teil
warum der russischen truppen sich die
titel auch führen und von den ukrainer
niedergemäht werden wie die fliegen und
es hilft auch nachrichten wie diese zu
erklären opel astra g zwei russische
soldaten kamen zur ukrainischen polizei
um nach dieselkraftstoff zu fragen
natürlich ist auch diese nachricht teil
der ukrainischen propaganda aber sie ist
ein weiteres beispiel von vielen von so
vielen dass sie einfach nicht mehr zu
leugnen sind sagen wir es ganz klar
russland hat ein ernsthaftes problem
wenn es um die ausbildung seiner
soldaten geht die meisten sind
wehrpflichtige die ihren militärdienst
ableisten man schätzt dass sogar ein
viertel der russischen elite truppen der
sogenannten cessnas wehrpflichtige sind
aber warum zum teufel ist dem so nun um
die hintergründe und ursachen zu
verstehen müssen wir uns zurück in die
zeit der sowjetunion beginnen
damals betrug die wehrpflicht zwei jahre
praktisch alles sowjetischen männer
mussten in der armee dienen wenn sie
volljährig wurden das hat er einen
vorteil die sowjetunion hatte eine menge
soldaten aber es gibt ein problem zwei
jahre sind nicht genug zeit um für die
heutigen ansprüche moderner
kriegsführung ausreichend trainieren zu
können nach dem zweiten weltkrieg begann
die großmächte vor allem die vereinigten
staaten und die sowjetunion ein
wettrüsten die waffensysteme wurden
immer komplexer und die komplexer die
waffen sind desto mehr ausbildungszeit
benötigen die soldaten die sie einsetzen
als reaktion auf diese entwicklung haben
immer mehr länder auch den wehrpflicht
abgeschafft und ihre ressourcen auf die
schaffung einer schlagkräftigen und
professionell berufsarmee konzentriert
seit einigen jahrzehnten unternehmen
fast alle armeen große anstrengungen in
diese richtung und russland ist da keine
ausnahme im jahr 2008 reduzierte kredit
wehrpflicht außerdem startete die armee
eine große rekrutierungskampagne sie
wollte soldaten die bereit waren eine
karriere beim militär zu machen
berufssoldaten die mehrere jahre in der
armee dienen können um die nötige
erfahrung in der modernen kriegsführung
zu sonnen und soldaten zu rekrutieren
braucht man vor allem zwei dinge geld
und junge menschen die sich verpflichten
wollen beide dinge sind in russland
mangelware und das liegt nicht nur an
der katastrophalen demographie des
landes
[Musik]
wo ich eine vorstellung davon zu geben
in der russischen armee diente etwa
850.000 soldaten davon sind jedoch nur
405.000 berufssoldaten und selbst diese
berufssoldaten bleiben nicht lange in
der armee eine nato feldwebel kann zb
durchschnittlich 15 bis 20 jahre dienen
in russland jedoch gibt es nur selten
soldaten die länger als vier jahre
dienen und diese zeitliche einschränkung
bringt schwerwiegende konsequenzen mit
sich eine kampfpilot der nato muss zum
beispiel mehr als 200 flugstunden
absolvieren um im kampf eingesetzt zu
werden und sogar für ukrainische piloten
gilt ein ähnlicher benchmark tja und in
russland in russland reichten hierzu
schon 100 stunden aus und wie gesagt
dies ist nur ein beispiel
denn wenn eines die russische armee
auszeichnet dann sind es stark
reduzierte standards und ausbildung bis
zur ausrüstung seht euch zum beispiel
dieses bild an oben ist ein russisches
erste hilfe sets zu sehen darunter das
standard kit der na wer hätte es gedacht
der ukrainische armee und ich weiß dass
viele von euch ist vor allem zwei fragen
durch den kopf gehen warum ist die
dienstzeit der russischen soldaten
eigentlich so kurz und wieso hat zum
beispiel in israel nicht ein ähnliches
problem wir alle wissen ja das ist auch
in israel eine zweijährige wehrpflicht
gibt sowohl für männer als auch für
frauen aber niemand würde sagen dass die
israelische armee schlecht ausgebildet
ist was hat israel also was russland
nicht hat nun das werden wir jetzt genau
unter die lupe nehmen
[Applaus]
eine armee ohne unteroffiziere
allgemein kann man sagen dass es zwei
möglichkeiten gibt in einer armee
einzutreten als soldat oder als offizier
profitieren werden auf akademien
ausgebildet in dieser hinsicht kann es
mit jeder anderen armen aufnehme
russische offiziere und generäle sind
genauso gut ausgebildet wie die des
anderen landes general valerie grassl
moral noch bis vor kurzem einen bei den
ausländischen kollegen hoch angesehener
fachmann das problem ist dass eine armee
mehr braucht als nur rekruten und
offiziere dazwischen gibt es eine
wichtige geschichte die alles
zusammenhält die unteroffiziere vor
allem die es gerade und
stabsunteroffizier bis zum oberfeldwebel
dies in soldaten mit jahrelanger
erfahrung den führungsaufgaben zu kommen
und die auch neuere gruppen ausbilden
können sie sind eine schlüsselfigur in
jeder armee und genau hier hat russland
eine sehr ernstes problem man muss sich
das so vorstellen
es wird geschätzt dass nur ein prozent
der rekruten nach dem militärdienst
wieder in die armee eintreten möchte das
bedeutet dass es nur sehr wenige
unteroffizier die neue soldaten
ausbilden können warum aber wollen so
wenige eine karriere in der russischen
armee machen sollte die militaristische
kultur russlands nicht dafür sorgen dass
sie sich nichts schöneres vorstellen
können
denkt daran dass putin sogar so weit
gegangen ist jugend mieten zu gründen
russische soldaten sollten theoretisch
doch wesentlich mehr patriotischen eifer
an den tag legen als die anderer länder
und ja dies stimmt durchaus der traum
vieler junger männer ist es sich zum
wehrdienst zu melden und dem vaterland
zu dienen das problem ist nur sobald sie
bei der armee ankommen werden sie mit
der harten realität konfrontiert und
diese gleicht in russland einem
regelrechten albtraum merkt euch den
begriff jedoch china ja ich weiß dass er
schwer auszusprechen ist aber viel
schlimmer ist das was sich dahinter
verbirgt
russischer soldat erschießt acht
kollegen auf sibirische militärbasis der
betreffende soldat erschoss seine
kameraden nachdem er monatelang
schikaniert und misshandelt worden war
jedoch china heißt direkt übersetzt
herrschaft der opas ein beschönigender
ausdruck für das schikanieren jüngere
wehrpflichtiger durch die ist ältere
diese schikane nimmt auch im heutigen
russland formen und ausmaße an die
seinesgleichen suchen um euch eine
vorstellung zu geben 2006 das heißt in
friedenszeiten war selbst noch die
todesursache war 40 prozent aller
verstorbenen soldaten 40 prozent
brachten sich also aus verzweiflung
selbst um und dies sind die offiziellen
geschönten zahlen eine in russland sehr
übliche praxis so werden zb auch die
viel alkohol toten im land vertuscht
indem in der statistik nicht
alkoholismus als todesursache aufgeführt
wird sondern nur eine der vielen folgen
davon so ist in einigen regionen
russlands erfrieren im freien eine der
häufigsten offiziellen todesursachen da
viele männer ins luft einfach draußen
erfrieren in wahrheit sind sie aber
natürlich aufgrund ihrer extremen
alkoholsucht gestorben denn ohne sie
wären sie nie in diese missliche
situation gekommen gemäss der
offiziellen zahlen starben im jahr 2014
15 rekruten direkt durch die schikanen
ihrer kameraden die tatsächlichen zahlen
dürften jedoch viel viel höher liegen
bei mindestens 500 pro jahr
internationales aufsehen erregte der
fall des damals 19-jährigen
wehrpflichtigen andrei sieg schoss
dieser wurde von vorgesetzten so schwer
misshandelt dass ihm beide beine die
genitalien und auch teile der rechten
hand amputiert werden mussten und wie
ihr euch vorstellen könnt ist ist bei
einer solch toxischen kultur nur logisch
dass die meisten russischen soldaten
nicht länger als vier jahre in der armee
bleiben sie halten es psychisch wie auch
für sind einfach nicht länger aus kein
patriotismus und kein geld der welt ist
ist ihnen wird gleichzeitig verfestigt
sich das system der jedoch china durch
eine art negative selektion selbst nur
die brutalsten zynischen und
menschenfeindlichen charaktere halten
durch steigen aus dem unteren rängen in
der armee auf und geben die schikane an
die neuankömmlinge weiter außerdem hat
man in russland nicht zum wehrdienst
eingezogen falls man gleich nach der
schule studieren geht jetzt so muss man
gute noten vorweisen und von einer
hochschule angenommen werden jeder der
intelligent genug lässt oder über gute
beziehungen verfügt versucht also der
brutalen wehrpflicht zu entgehen um das
in der armee lässt nicht nur die geistig
leistungsschwachen uns sozial
benachteiligten landen vor allem aus den
ärmsten regionen des landes eine
ausnahme stellen die golden kippte er
ist die logik ida aber diese müssen
natürlich nicht mit dem fußvolk dienen
ihnen wird das studium an den
kaderschmieden der armee des mit der
geheimnisse des fsb als der dienst
anerkannt hierbei handelt es sich aber
um eine eher kleine gruppe mehr oder
weniger verzogener millionärs münchen
was diese sogar durch arrogantes gehabe
in sozialen netzwerken unter beweis
stellen von einer bürger armee die sich
aus einem breiten spektrum der
gesellschaft rekrutiert oder gar die
intellektuellen fähigsten anlockt kann
also keine rede sein es herrscht wie
gesagt vom anfang bis zum ende eine
negative selektion um den kreislauf aus
brutalität und abstumpfung zu
durchbrechen wolle 2009 die erste
unteroffiziers akademie russlands
eröffnet sie soll den mangel an unter
offizieren beheben aber das reicht bei
einer so großen armee vorn und hinten
nicht jedes jahr machen 2009 unter
offizieren abschluss russland bräuchte
jedoch noch viele viele mehr und da es
nicht ausreichend gut ausgebildete
unteroffiziere gibt werden die
bataillone oft von wehrpflichtigen
geführt die nur ein jahr erfahrung haben
sowie ist in der sowjetunion üblich war
wird also wieder ein großes schauspiel
dargeboten junge truppen zurück geben
vor ihre bataillone zu führen und die
wehrpflichtigen tun so als würden sie
gehorchen gut ist werden sich aber
vielleicht viele fragen wenn die jedoch
china die russische armee der schwächt
warum macht putin nicht einfach selbst
ordnung und verbietet sie nun ganz
einfach weil auch er weiß
dann wohl alles zusammenbrechen würde
die gesamte psychologische struktur und
führung der russischen streitkräfte
braucht eigentlich auf nichts anderem
auf als einer durch gewalt und
unterdrückung geschaffenen hackordnung
schließlich entspricht die kultur jede
auch nur der jeder gesellschaft aus der
sie ihre fangquoten bezieht nur in ambri
fi zierte und noch brutaler vor nebenbei
bemerkt ist diese brutale kultur der
grausamkeit auch eine grundlage für die
russischen gräueltaten in der ukraine
dies betrifft sowohl die unteren ränge
als auch die führung die terror gegen
zivilbevölkerung schon immer gerne ob in
tschetschenien krieg wie in syrien als
probates mittel zur färbung des gegners
eingesetzt hat und wenn man ihnen die
ordnungsmittel schikane und
unterdrückung wegnehmen würde bliebe von
der russischen armee nichts weiter übrig
als ein wilder haufen aggressiver
chauvinisten und abgestumpft aws
empfänger man muss schließlich auch
bedenken dass in den truppen kaum mit
ihrer gebildete schichten aus moskau
oder st petersburg dienen um die moral
der zivilbevölkerung im russischen
kernland nicht zu gefährden verheißt
ihnen erster linie angehörige ethnischer
minderheiten aus den asiatischen teil
früher gab es in jeder einheit
politoffizier die mit ihrer
psychologischen ausbildung zusätzlich
führt of china für moral gehorsam und
linientreu in der truppe sollten doch
diese würden nach dem fall der
sowjetunion abgeschafft was blieb ist
nur noch das prinzip gewalt von oben
gewalt und natürlich ein bürokratischer
moloch dessen starre hierarchien und
vorschriften jegliches intelligente und
eigenständige denken und handeln schon
im keim ersticken einführungs prinzip
dass diejenigen moderner sich aus
freiheitlich demokratischen
gesellschaften rekrutieren gehen
diametral entgegensteht in unserem video
über die israelische armee haben wir
auch die fähigkeit ihrer einheiten
hervorgehoben selbstständig und autark
agieren zu können zb durch den ihrer
verbindung zum hauptquartier gekappt
wurde eine fähigkeit in der die
russische armee schon traditionell aus
mangel an vertrauen nicht ausgebildet
ist die ukraine waren sich dieser
systemischen schwäche durchaus bewusst
und setzen bei ihren
verteidigungsposition dort an wo sie die
russischen einheit isolieren und damit
führungslos machen konnten um das durch
unteroffiziers mangel und
zusammengebrochene kommunikation
entstandene chaos an der front also noch
irgendwie in den griff zu bekommen
müssen die generäle höchstselbst an die
vorderste linie wo ihre positionen
aufgrund der hervorragenden durch die
usa unterstützten
aufklärungsmöglichkeiten in kaum einem
fall unentdeckt bleiben ein gefundenes
fressen zur scharfschützen und
präzisions geschosse und ihr fragt euch
vielleicht ist es wirklich lade mir
putins schuld dass die russische armee
so schlecht da steht was wurde
eigentlich aus der viel beschworenen
armeereform des kreml wo ist der
einfluss des genialen generals valerie
gerasimov geblieben nun spitzt die ohren
denn nun führen wir alle fäden zusammen
[Musik]
des diktators neue kleider
die frage die sich alle stellen lautet
natürlich wie könnte sich putin
überhaupt ist so arg verkalkulieren
alles deutet darauf hin dass russland
ein blitzkrieg erwartet hatte sie
dachten elite einheiten könnten kharkiv
binnen drei bis vier tagen einnehmen die
durch den russischen geheimdienst fsb
bestochen ukrainische armee würde keinen
widerstand leisten und die
zivilbevölkerung die russen als bisher
mit offenen armen empfangen vorsorglich
wollte den us-truppen aufgetragen sie
sollten ihre parade uniformen für den
triumphzug durch kiew mit gegen ihre
panzer nehmen ja das ist kein witz auch
kein witz in den fahrzeugkolonnen gegen
kiew und hip aufbrachen fuhren
zahlreiche gefängniswagen und mobile
krematorien der geheimpolizei mit um
alle die nicht freundlich gesonnen
ukraine zu verhaften nach russland zu
verschleppen oder gar vor ort zu
ermorden und ihre leichen zu verbrennen
doch offensichtlich ist dieser ebenso
nahe wie grausam mit plan nicht
aufgegangen
[Musik]
die frage ist daher was denn eigentlich
die ganze zeit der russische
geheimdienst und die aufklärung
betrieben haben haben sie wladimir putin
nicht bezüglich seine siegeschancen
geraten vergesst bitte nicht dass es
sich hier nicht um eine kleine
fehlkalkulation handelt sondern um eine
ausgewachsene invasion bei der russland
mehr als 23.000 tote zu beklagen und
einen epochenwandel eingeleitet hat bei
dem es nur verlieren kann und so seltsam
ist auch klingen mag alles deutet darauf
hin dass ausgerechnet der ausgekochte ex
kgb la putin opfer eines systems
geworden ist aus dem hervorgegangen war
und dass er selbst motiviert hatte ja
nicht nur die revolution frisst ihre
kinder auch die korruption und
ironischerweise spielt sowohl bei putins
aufstieg als auch bei seinem fall eine
ganz bestimmte zahl eine besondere last
symbolträchtige rolle 100 millionen
dollar wovon ich spreche nun in unserer
vollsten video über das scheitern des
kapitalismus und russland haben ja
darüber erzählt wie nach dem
zusammenbruch der sowjetunion anfang der
90er jahre selbst die
lebensmittelversorgung der russischen
bevölkerung durch lieferungen aus dem
ausland sichergestellt werden musste im
gegenzug dafür lieferte russland das
einzige was uns noch hatte rohstoffe
dass bei der die was aber nur relativ
wenigen bekannt ist genau dieses
hilfsprogramm nutzte der damals junge
premier putin um seinen ersten richtig
großen batzen geld zu stehlen
[Musik]
sozusagen das grundkapital mit denen er
dann seinen kometenhaften aufstieg bis
zum alleinherrscher des landes
finanziert putin war vom kgb in den
magistrat der stadt sollte petersburg
gewechselt und zur rechten hand des
bürgermeisters geworden im unterstand
das lebensmittel für rohstoffe programm
der fünf millionen metropole das heißt
er kontrollierte alle lieferungen und
musste diese abzeichnen es ging um den
export von rohstoffen im wert von 100
millionen dollar im austausch gegen
lebensmittel für die bürger sankt
petersburgs der clou an der ganzen
geschichte die rohstoffe wurden zwar ins
ausland verschifft aber die lebensmittel
kamen irgendwie nie ins tak petersburg
an und es gibt absolut wasserdichte
beweise dafür dass putin hier die
verantwortung trägt das ergebnis war
dass die menschen der stadt ohne
lebensmittel da standen putin und seine
clique jedoch 100 millionen dollar
startkapital ein sagten konnte und nun
lasst uns 30 jahre in die zukunft
sprengt dies ist eines der seltenen
bilder des ehemaligen chefs der
berüchtigten küste abteilungen des fsg
auslandsnachrichtendienstes sergej
besser vor der invasion in die ukraine
erhielt er aus dem geheimen
schattenhaushalt des kreml ein budget
von 100 millionen dollar mit dem er in
der ukraine vor allem innerhalb der
armee ein netzwerk von verrätern
aufbauen sollte und da sah besser da wie
damals putin wohl seinen großen moment
gekommen wenn auch anders als man dies
annehmen würde ist ja auch ein eher
mühsam es riskantes und undankbares
unterfangen so ein verräter netzwerke in
einem feindesland aufzubauen das doch
gar keinen bock mehr auf eine russische
nationalistische diktatur hat ganz nach
britischem vorbild sagte er das geld
also lieber selbst ein und meldete
seinen chef im kreml mission
accomplished die ukraine ist eine über
reife frucht wir müssen sie nur pflücken
in jeder stadt warten tausende unserer
gesamten auf unseren einmarsch und putin
gab daraufhin das kommando auspackt die
parade uniformen ein wir sehen uns auf
dem majdan gut besser da wollte wohl
auch einfach nicht derjenige sein der
das luftschloss putins vom neuen groß
russischen reich platzen lässt eines
heran der immer mehr nur ja sager und
speichellecker in seiner umgebung zuließ
und eklige widerrede die seinem
wunschdenken zuwiderlief erbarmungslos
unter besser da und seine gesamte
führungsriege sitzen mittlerweile in
einem der berüchtigten
hochsicherheitsgefängnis und valerie
gerasimov der rockstar der russischen
armee wurde an die front mitten in den
ukrainischen granatenhagel geschickt der
klaren ansage entweder bringst du das
alles wieder in ordnung oder du brauchst
gar nicht mehr wiederzukommen für putin
ist die richtung klar er kann gerasimov
bester tot als lebendig bei bedarf zum
sündenbock für seine fehlschläge ende
ukraine abstempeln dann könnt ihn
endgültig des micro management des
krieges übernehmen es wäre das erste mal
dass ein politiker so etwas tut wir
haben dass wir dann kriegst in der
damalige us-präsident lyndon johnson so
weit dass er die kleinsten details vom
oval office aus steuerte das ergebnis
war eine absolute blamage für das us
militär und auch die deutschen haben ja
schon so ihre erfahrungen mit dem tricks
micro management eines politikers tja
und hier haben wir eine weitere dicke
wurzel des übels an dem ausland krankt
es hat sich im laufe der jahre zu einer
klassischen personenkult diktatur
entwickelt und das drückt sich in
erschreckendem maße auch auf das militär
und die geheimdienste aus klar zu zeiten
der sowjetunion war russland auch eine
uneingeschränkte diktatur aber das
wichtigste entscheidungsgremium war das
politbüro der zentralausschuss der
kommunistischen partei dort saßen bis zu
35 mitglieder die alle entscheidungen
miteinander diskutierten heute gibt es
das politische politbüro nicht mehr denn
jetzt haben wir das hier
das ganze mag wie eine karikatur
aussehen aber dies ist die russische
realität ein politisches system in dem
ein mann die macht hat alle
entscheidungen zu treffen ohne ein
gegengewicht zu haben 0 checks and
balances und ja das macht sich auch beim
militär bemerkbar ein beispiel den fast
allen ländern werden die streitkräfte
vom generalstab geleitet der wiederum
dem verteidigungsministerium unterstellt
aber russland hat daneben noch eine
spezial armee die direkt auf putin
zugeschnitten ist eine art nationalgarde
unter dem namen oscar bekannt
[Musik]
sie wurde 2016 von putin höchstselbst
geschaffen sie hat mehr als 340.000
soldaten und wird direkt von wladimir
putin geführt mit anderen worten mehr
als ein drittel der 850.000 russischen
soldaten sind nicht bestandteil der
reguläre nach mb das heißt sie
unterstehen nicht general gerasimov oder
sergej schoigu ihre befehl erhalten sie
direkt vom präsidenten
das mag euch überraschen aber dies ist
eine konstante in fast allen autoritären
regimes und viele denken noch immer dass
das militär in einer militaristischen
diktatur besser funktioniert als in
einer demokratie doch autoritäre führer
haben nur selten volles vertrauen in ihr
militär und das zu recht darum hat auch
putin seine eigene prätorianergarde
geschaffen im prinzip ist diese
nationalgarde jedoch keine truppe die in
krieg kämpfen soll dafür ist die
überhaupt nicht ausgebildet
man könnte sagen dass sie eine art
militarisierte polizeitruppe ist ihr
ziel ist ist die territoriale kontrolle
russlands selbst zu sichern das heißt
aufständische und terroristische gruppen
zu bekämpfen und proteste zu
unterdrücken aber denk dran russland
befindet sich ja offiziell nicht im
krieg nicht wahr laut dem kreml ist der
einmarsch in die ukraine nur eine
spezialoperation um ein gebiet voller
antirussische aufständischer zu
entnazifizierung das fazit zu ziehen
versuchte auch die rhodia an die front
zu schicken und das ergebnis zwölf
mitglieder der austria wurden entlassen
weil sie sich weigerten eine invasion
teilzunehmen putin musste sogar den
vize-chef der oscar die ja verhaften
lassen so stark war der aufruhr
innerhalb ihrer truppe die ihm
eigentlich am loyalsten sein sollte aber
denkt mal drüber nach diese
nationalgarde ist nicht zu einem krieg
als solchen ausgebildet sie an die front
zu schicken steht für viele ein
todesurteil da systemische brutalität
korruption misstrauen einem krankenhaus
aus lügen gesellt sich nun also auch die
absolute stümperhaftigkeit eines führers
das ganze politische system des landes
auf sich ausgerichtet und alle
mechanismen zur korrektur seiner fehler
ausgeschaltet hat wer würde es wagen ihn
zu widersprechen praktisch alle
schlüsselfiguren im militär und in der
militärindustrie werden vom präsidenten
handverlesen seine partei einiges
russland hat was alle sitze im parlament
von den 450 sitzen in der russischen
duma gehören 325 der partei pis das
bedeutet dass niemand putins eigene
fehleinschätzungen in frage stellen kann
einschließlich der invasion in der
ukraine
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt kann niemand mehr
leugnen dass putin seine streitkräfte
falsch eingeschätzt hat er richtete
damit dass seine truppen tief in wenigen
tagen erobern und die ukraine die russen
mit offenen armen empfangen würden falls
dies nicht klappen würde sein plan b die
bombardierung tieres vor aber auch diese
musste aufgrund der miserablen
logistischen fähigkeiten der russischen
streitkräfte abgebrochen werden in einer
funktionierenden demokratie hätten es
die geheimdienste leichter gehabt ihre
präsidenten zu widersprechen in die
ungeschönte wahrheit ins gesicht zu
sagen die generelle selbst könnten eine
realistische strategie ausarbeiten die
auf einer gründlichen kenntnis ihrer
militärischen stärke berühmt aber in
diesem fall haben wir es mit einem
ehemaligen kgb-offizier zu tun der über
keine militärische ausbildung verfügt
und entscheidungen trifft ohne dass ihn
jemand die stirn bietet mit genau
derselben arroganz gegenüber den
ratschlägen der generalität hat auch
schon hitler den krieg verloren aber der
war wenigstens mal gefreiten ersten
weltkrieg und so kam es wie es kommen
musste die russischen truppen ziehen
sich laut und kritischen berichten aus
den gebieten nahe kiew zurück putin
versucht nun seine truppen neu zu
gruppieren um in einer neuen offensive
wenigstens noch den doors erobern zu
können und die besetzten gebiete in
fügen zu halten schließlich geht es dort
auch um die wichtige wasserversorgung
der krim die russischen truppen
versuchen aus ihren kasten spiele der
ersten beiden monate so lernen sie gehen
nun besondere und vorsichtiger vor das
russische militär muss sein personal
rotieren seine batterie oder erneuern
und gefallene ersetzen und putin vor
allem die mangelhafte psychologische
vorbereitung der streitkräfte wie auch
der bevölkerung auf den langen
entbehrungsreichen krieg nachholen denn
was wir euch noch nicht verraten haben
im jahr 2018 hat der kreml herrscher
eigentlich die institution der
politkommissar wiederbelebt sie stecken
hinter vielen propaganda projekt zur
unterstützung des krieges militärische
agitprop erweckt den anschein dass eine
mehrheit der öffentlichkeit den kurs des
gremiums und seiner streitkräfte
unterstützt die polit kommissare sorgen
zusammen mit den priestern der
orthodoxen kirchen auch dafür dass die
front rückkehrer öffentlich als helden
begrüßt werden die eine heilige pflicht
erfüllt haben sie agitieren und zwingen
wert wichtige dienst verträge zu
unterschreiben und führen
prophylaktische gespräche mit
jugendlichen die gegen den krieg sind
putin will sie nun mit weitgehenden
vollmachten ausstatten und wieder voll
in der 8 die verankern denn in den
schrecklichsten momente des krieges auto
auch sally die repressive autorität
seiner kommissare gezielt aus die frage
lautet daher wohin wird dies alles
führen dass putin damit noch die chance
irgendetwas zu gewinnen hier zu sehen
wir uns in den nächsten beiden teilen
dieser trilogie die waffen und
rüstungstechnik shen und natürlich auch
sehr heiklen logistischen aspekte des
krieges an bis dahin könnt ihr über
diese dinge gerne gegen kommentarbereich
diskutieren und uns auch anregungen dazu
geben denkt ihr zum beispiel dass unsere
analyse ein realistisches bild der
russischen armee hervor gebracht hat
haben wir etwas übersehen welche
faktoren fallen euch noch ein und zu was
wird die russische armee überhaupt noch
in der lage sein im verlaufe dieses
krieges und erst recht danach also
nichts wie los haut in die tasten und
zeigt uns eure meinung ich hoffe dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat was ja
die gäste ein leichtes mit meinen
freunden und fans nicht das abo mit
glöckchen um keines unserer videos mehr
zu verpassen natürlich freunde das auch
jederzeit über eine spende von euch mit
der er uns helfen dieses projekt
weiterzuführen dem paper link dazu
findet ihr in der beschreibung unter dem
video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]